[Musique]
du coup
euh on va faire un petit tour de table
pour se présenter si ça vous VO
comme connais personne
encore qu'est-ce que c'est la lucarne
d'Arian la lucarne d'an c'est une
association ok tu connais un peu les
chantiers d'insertion tu as déjà
été c'est pour l'insertion des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi ou qui était sous
ma justice ou en détention et c'est pour
favoriser leur insertion et l'activité
économique
non c'est très bien c'est tout qui est
considéré comme ayant une difficulté à
retourner à l'emplo les personnesus ont
de
fact des difficultés à retourner au
marché du travail pour plein de raisons
CONI c'est là j'ai fait quelques
formations j'ai fait une habation
électrique je sais
pasér ou c'est tu l' fa
aussi dernir j'ai SST en sécurité bien
aussi pas mal maintenant j'aimerais bien
passer la la formation RG
lumière voilà voilà moi c'est John je
suis technicien polyvalent à la lugane
d'Ariane je fais du montage de scène de
la régie lumière prochainement peut-être
de la régie son
euh j'aime beaucoup
l'événementiel la sonorisation AG gros
[Musique]
volume il est ici depuis Mo 5 mois merci
et John depuisu début juilletb Ju et
donc moi j 20 ans nouveau salarié à la
lual j'ai déjà des on va dire entre
guillemets des expériences dans le monde
de l'audiovisuel et ce qui m'a poussé à
rentrer dans le domaine de l'audiovisuel
c'est on va
dire mon amour un petit peu pour la
musique tout ce qui est créativité
j'aime beaucoup la créativité et pouvoir
m'exprimer librement
et donc du coup c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi l'UD visuel l'article 432 du code
PIN c'est ça la liberté
d'expressionite leode
pénal et bienvenu merci ah merci quandme
il y en a un qui va
dire on avait fait une inscription à
trois formations à la gessif donc
celle-ci produire diffuser vendre un
spectacle et la
troisième construire un budget OK et en
fait on a fait plein de SST étalés dans
le temps parce qu'on a des nouveaux qui
arrivaient qui devaient arriver en fait
ils sont sorti de détenenstion 2 mois
plus tard ça complique les choses bon ça
a été un un bazar ouais ouais oui vousos
vos candidat c'est plutôt des personnes
qui viennent du monde enfin qui ont été
détenu et en fait on est un chantier
d'insertion spécialisé là-dedans donc
100 % de nos personnes accompagn sont
sortant de prison ou en mesure
alternativ ou en mesure alternative à la
sortie de détention donc ouais c'est ça
j'ai bien compris que vous avez pas de
mon sur 2023 non comme ils sont sur des
contrats de 6 mois et que dès qu'ils
trouvent un emploi ils sortent et ils
sont remplacés on en a en fait le la
durée moyenne est de 10 mois dans la
structure donc il y en a qui vont rester
que 6 mois d'autres qui vont rester que
mois et d'autres qui vont rester un an
et
demi comme ça à peu près tu fais comme
ça c'est Mar tu fais fait comme ça parce
que si tu fais attends jeis essayer de
le refire parce que des fois quand pour
t'exliquer regarde en fait t tour tu
vois regarde tu vois je regarde je fais
ça j'essaie de parce que c'est pas
facile moi j'ai tellement l'habitude là
je le tourne ouais et en fait je viens
viens tu vois le câ il vient comme ça je
viens juste le poser là en fait ah ok et
en fait tac et pareil là en fait vas-y
je sais pas pourquoi tu fais ce
mouvement de
[Rires]
choline elle
gringo ça le CRE son action après tu
vois lui il le fait dans l'autre sens
tant que tu arrives à le même résultat
on est d'accord comm point important qui
résume la vie d'un TOS le roulage de
câble c'est dans le top quand même
c'està dire que un newb il arrive il
fait ça et tout le monde le voit quoi h
tu
vois en plus qu un geste que tu peux
faire pour aider un peu tout le monde il
y a 20000 câbles à rouler en général tu
vois c'est bon esprit c'est bon esprit
quand quand c'est en démontage que tu
viennes tu roules les câbles voilà autre
chose qu'il faut qu'il sache quand il
arrive dans une salle de spectacle Son
on verra après des projecteurs ah merci
Chris à partir de là j'ai accès à mes
projecteurs pourquoi j'ai accès à mes
projecteurs parce que cette table est
reliée par ce câble regardeir c'est
marqué derrière voilà marqué c'est du GX
d'accord DMX le DMX c'est relié au bloc
d'accord damx c'est un protocole al
protocole tu vois ce que ça veut dire
comme mot ou pas euh oui en gros c'est
un une une forme de commande
c'est-à-dire en gros dans un DMX tu as
le DMX envoie des informations au bloc
pour lui dire bah quand je fais ça tu
fais ça euh voilà et donc là c'est vrai
pour tous les projecteurs donc je peux
les allumer les uns après les autres
d'accord et comment tu sais quel
projecteur est correspond à quel bah bah
tu fais comme ça hein tu sais tu fais
tuer alors des fois quand c'est dans une
bonne salle bien bien carrée en fait
chaque circuit est noté donc quand on
branche un projecteur on sait où va le
retrouver ce qu'on appelle au patch bon
ici c'est un peu le bordel donc en fait
en vrai tu regardes et puis hop là tu
vois B après tu peux te faire un petit
pense bê B justement quand tu arrives
dans une salle tu te fais un pense bê ou
tu te mets un scotch et là tu vas
renoter latéraux par latéraux tu vois
d'accord
catch bon B c'est bon on est
au les employeurs je pense qu'il faut
qu'on les prépare à l'accueil il y a des
problématiques sociales et humaines
qu'on peut pas nier qu'ils ont parce que
il y a une destruction complète de ce
qu'ils ont été par la détention qui fait
que
euh ils sont plus fragiles et que je
pense qu'il faut déjà faire un travail
sur ça avec les lieux et aussi faire un
travail de déconstruction de leur gros à
priori enfin ce que j'ai entendu de ce
qu'elle m'a dit c'est des problématiques
que tu peux rencontrer avec n'importe
quel salarié dans le monde entier en
fait sauf que elle elle relie ça avec la
condamnation de la personne donc elle
dit en fait tout ça c'est lié au fait
que ce soit des personnes passées s de
justice et cette confusion en fait euh
je la trouve dangereuse en fait parce
que moi ce qu'elle m'a dit c'est je
n'accueillerai plus jamais une personne
sous mon de justice dans ma structure
c'est aussi une injonction
contradictoire qui nous est fait dans le
chantier d'insertion pour le coup on
peut dire tout ce qu'on peut dire pour
préparer le terrain mais il faut aussi
que les employurs soient clairs quand
vous prenez quelqu'un qui est encore en
apprentissage vous ne pouvez pas avoir
les exigences que vous auriez d'un
régisseur à guéri et pourquoi vous
prenez quelqu'un qui en apprentissage il
y a des raisons que nous on peut bien
entend et moi je peux bien entendre des
raisons économiques parce que souvent
c'est un emploi aid un machin un truc et
tout donc pour la structure c'est plus
facile et il y a des raisons il y a des
raisons que les régisseurs AG guuérri
ils ont pas envie de se fourvoyer dans
des emmerdes jusqu'en haut du coup pour
des tarifs qui sont pour des prix vous
pouvez pas les payer donc soyez honnête
avec ça et si vous êtes honnête avec ça
ça il faut le dire aux employeurs si
vous êtes honnête avec ça essayez de
construire un accompagnement si vous
voulez vraiment employer quelqu'un pour
que ça se passe du mieux possible on
parle de personnes qui on passé x temps
derriè les baroutait privé de liberté
mais aussi d'autonomie et il y a des
choses qui sont pour nous évidentes qui
le sont pas pour eux ils sont assez
doués je trouve pour respecter les
horaires sur les sorties culturel j'ai
jamais eu de problème par contre prévoir
son petit en cas aucun l'avait fait
parce que ça en fait c'est des trucs
qu'ils ont complètement oublié de faire
et d'apprendre je pense pendant la
détention il va y avoir des trucs qui
leur semblent complètement venu de
l'espace à nos salariés en insertion
c'est comme quelqu'un qui voudrait
apprendre à la fois à jongler et
apprendre une langue étrangère enfin
c'est on peut pas franchement ça c'est
un MAA exemple moi je fais les deux
c'est facile j'is les deux en oui je
sais que tu fais du monocycle en
travaillantou mais si on leur apprend à
être autonome à anticiper ils
apprendront à apprendre et ce sera plus
facile après pour apprendre des
nouvelles fonctions pour apprendre des
nouveaux automatisme pour le c'est là où
elle a raison parce que apprendre
l'autonomie ça prend pas si mois c'est
très très long surtout quand tu as eu un
fonctionnement où on t'a enlevé ton
autonomie pendant 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans
enfin tu
vois
non on est bien là non non il faut que
le point chaud moi tu vois regarde le
point chaud moi je vais mettre au milieu
du carré là le point chaud c'est
l'endroit où la lumière elle plus
intense faut qu'elle soit sur ma gueule
en
fait là tu tu es trop en bas faut que tu
remontes attends je vais le baisser un
peu attends 2
secondes Chris il va falloir que tu
resserres ton faisceau là il est
beaucoup trop grand tu vois tout à
l'heure on a réussi à rentrer le rond
quasiment dans le carré tu vois ouais
mais là je touche quoi là derrièour
c'est ce que je fais j'ai l'impression
que c'est bon
est bleu du coup du coup mets du
bleu 60 ok c l'autre du
coup comme
ça
[Musique]
vous décrivez une situation associée à
une
émotion vous l'écrivez en dessous de la
feuille hein je suis en train de
chercher d'accord il y a pas de
souci l'idée c'est de d'arriver à
décrypter ce qui se passe en fait à ce
moment-là Noël est-ce que tu veux
commencer moi j'ai marqué pour la
première fois de ma vie je suis autonome
dans mon propre logement un réel plaisir
une grande liberté d'accord c'est la
première fois de ta vie que tu es tout
seul dans ton
appartement que j'ai un logement tu as
un logement autonome en autonomie en
autonomie totale et alors du coup pensé
c'était bah une cuisine une douche un
clicclac et mon matériel studio puis
qu'il est dans un gardemeuble donc j'ai
pensé à ça enfin la superficie de la
pièce si je pouvais si tu pouvais mettre
tout ça dedans organiserancer ta mon
propre espace à toi ta petite cabane
quoi et après j'ai je me suis arrêté à
émotion bah j'ai ressenti une grande
émotion de bien manger et de pouvoir
pratiquer de la musique et j'ai ressenti
des frissons une fois que j'ai installé
ouais enfin ouais la première fois que
j'ai cuisiné que j'ai pris une douche
que j'ai regardé la télé enfin voilà que
j'ai pu sortir seul entrer et sortir
seul de l'appartement
oui donc c'est quand même tout un
univers qui s'ouvre à toi et sur lequel
tu te dis wou waouh ouais voà mais
maintenant tu sais que c'est c'est un
univers de liberté en fait de liberté
h
moi je connais des gens qui sont hyper
bon en live studio c'est juste pas
intéressant ce qu'ils font c'est très
compliqué ça parce qu' y a vraimentas
une autre énergie tuas je vais prendre
je vais prendre un exemple je vais
prendre un
exemple
ccesum studio tu fais chier tu vois bon
mais inversement parce qu'en studio
c'est un autre travail tout ça pour dire
queon est un super outil pour composer
après l'outil chacun l'utilise comme il
veut d'accord je sais pas si vous avez
vu mais à côté là j'ai plein de
sons voilà c'est des sons un peu comme
çaambance des bruit d'ambiance ça peut
être des boucles ça peut être comme là
on appelle ça des one shot c'est pour ça
que c'estutilisé en musique électrique
donc on peut recomposer un morceau en
live là voilà quand j'envoie ça j'envoie
toute la ligne d'accord donc ça aussi
c'est très pratique moi pour le moment
je vous demande pas de savoir composer
sur hbleton je vous demande de savoir
ouvrir une piste audio de mettre des
sons sur cette piste audio et de
préparer à pouvoir les diffuser en
direct d'accord puce qu'en théâtre on
est en direct OK ou même en ça ça va ça
enfin ça va en tout cas vous voyez
l'idée vous voyez l'esprit euh et tout
ça on va le le préparer avec les
comédiens et les artistes ah bah oui ça
se prépare et c'est pour ça qu'il y a du
temps de création c'est pour ça qu'il y
a du temps de travail c'est pour ça que
quand on est en création bah on met des
projecteurs on essaye des trucs moi mon
objectif c'est que dans 3 mois quel que
soit votre place même si vous faites
plus de son plus de machin dans l'absolu
on installe une régie et vous êtes
capable de le faire en autonomie
d'accord j'ai vu une annonce je crois
que CTA c'est pour Disney cétait ça
Disney et en gros quand j'ai vu bon il y
avait des choses différentes mais après
c'est plus régie tu vois et voilà c'est
plus technicien alors j'ai j'ai fait en
sorte que c'est vrai que je peux changer
aussi quelques compétences je peux en
rajouter ou je peux c'est dire que il
faut l'adapter à l'ffich de posteff de
poste ouaisouais c'est ça après je pas
allerav en tant que
technicien lumière euh je sais pas moi
euh dans un endroit où il y a peu de
personnes par exemple s'il y a 10
personnes je vais pas aller travailler
il faut qu'ille au moin un minimum non
mais tu peux pas c'est pas possible
pourquoi avir des exigence de plein en
plus faut savoir que dans la culture ou
dans l'événementiel quand tu dis je vais
pas travailler 45 heur par semaine il y
a des semaines tu travailler à 60h des
semaines travailler à moins parce qu'il
y aura un gros événement et que là tu
travaille jour et nuit et je va dire tu
peux pas dire moi je vais faire mes 35
heur tranquille tu c'est pas possible
c'est pas des alors tu fais un autre
métier tu vas travailler chez quand je
travaille il faut que ça me plaise aussi
ça me plaît pas je vais pas cont après
alors il y a deux choses il y a c'est
pas postuler à toutes les sin si tu
postules parce que je je te dis d'abord
tu tuacquè une expertise et ça c'est pas
rien expertise justement et tu montres
que tu es organisé ordonné comme tu dis
je vais postuler a pas de problème je
vais postuler si m'accepte ben je vais
refuser parce que moi j'aimerais pas ce
que c'est pourquoi tu dis que tu vas
refuser de tu LC renuler pour quelque
chose que j'aime pas mais tu sais pas si
tu vas aimer l'entreprise ou pas c'est
quand tu y travailles ça fait quelques
quelques semaines que je viens un peu et
je t'entends toujours dire je cherche je
cherche je cherche maintenant tu peux
plus chercher comme ça tu passes à l'AE
c'està-dire qu'en gros tu tu envoies des
tu fais des lettres de motivation et tu
les envoies j'étais sur Sogo j'ai pas
terminé Sogo après j'ai faire ça jeis
plein de choses en même temps là je suis
complètement bah voilà toi qui organisé
organisé mais quand tu es arrivé moi
j'étais déjà dessus j'étais sur Soo
j'allais répondre à ça j'allais regarder
j'allais après tuas arrivé tu m'as
parlé c'est pas ça c'est que fait trop
de Ch
oup qui est sortie de la B ouais si tu
en trouves tu bah voilà fais en sorte
qu'elle soit alimenté VO là
c'estbligé donc par contre ce qu'il va
falloir faire c'est ramener des XLR on a
prévu des XLR Jack là faut ramener pour
arriver jusque là quoi ok e Joris il
nous faut quoi là regarde il nous faut
ça pour relier les deux là ils vont empl
normalement tu vois B faut aller au AMPL
tu avoir du SP derrière les
amplis quand tu les allumes es
s'allument ou pas attends attendsas rel
les de tuas relié celle ou pas donc tu
es rentré dans quoi là-bas je suis
rentré dans du XLR femelle j'ai mis du
X channel 1
Chel pourre
S l'air qu'on sache on
est jamais le de
ok c'est allumé ou pas il y a il y a du
courant tout est ok alors attends bougez
[Musique]
pas là il est de marche non la tienne
elle marche
pasy laisse comme ça c'est bon oublieé
elle a marché mais c'est éteint
gr on va on va préparer une texture de
fond là tu
vois
en fait l'idée mais pas trop fort en
fait l'idée c'est que ce soit juste
suggéré en fait tu
vois tu vois ça s'en va tu vois que des
petits événements tuis on se fait un
fond comme ça et après tous les petits
événements qu'on a là tu te les mets sur
une piste il faudra que tu fasses de
l'édition c'estd l'idée c'est que tu les
coupes juste ils passent tu vois on les
entend à peine tac tac par exemple j'en
choisis un je les mets sur une P après
j'ess tu les mets tous et après tu les
tu ave des distances tu on va s'écouter
le montage du coup si ça vous
dit celui-ci donc c'est ce gros truc là
mais il y a un petit peu avant de
froissement si on peut aussi entendre un
petit le petit froissement qu'il y a
avant c'est bien c'est vraiment tout
micro juste avant ce gros truc mais
c'est effectivement ce gros truc il a un
petit truc qui vient c'est ça que tu
veux entendre plus celui-ci
[Musique]
là juste juste le tout petit ouais ouais
ouais c'est ça exact le tout petit plus
le gros qui vients ah le gros le gros tu
veux l'entendre aussi ah oui oui oui
tout avant en vrai c'est inule tout
avant c'est inutile c'est ça CIT juste
12 et 18 ouais juste 12 et 18 ces deux
là super merci
beaucoup bon voilà
bon c'est bon là renvoie le premier du
[Musique]
coup je suis désemparé ici parfois et je
déteste demander de
[Musique]
l'aide quand tu me parles à moi tu me
parles pas de la même façon quand tu
parles à Lou tu parles à jorisce que tu
parles à ton pote et ça c'est vraiment
la connaissance de qu'est-ce que c'est
que la communication et comment soi-même
on
communique alors au niveau de la
communication c'est codifié au niveau du
langage donc c'est une communication
formelle régie par des normes on va dire
il y a une attitude posturale
verbal il y a des des formules par
exemple tu es pas en situation ouais je
sais clairement à tout niveaux hein mais
je suis pas dans une position formelle
actuellement B si là on est en position
de travail tu vois donc je m'en fous que
tu es un ballon tu vois c'est pas ça la
question simplement faut considérer que
quand vous êtes là on est juste dans un
dans une relation de travail oui donc
entre collègu après y a une nuance aussi
entre notre attitude là présentement sur
un exercice et notre attitude en
prestation on aura pas directement ouis
mais il faut déjà s'entraîner non non
c'est toi qui cherche du boulot faut
jamais l'oublier ah oui bien sûr JBI tu
fais quoi là j'écris des notes ton
téléphone il est
où non JBI écoute franchement tu as quel
âge on dirait ma petite fille quoi
regarde il est là tu crois c'est parce
que comme tu parles avec les autres mais
tuécoutes justement parce que ça éc
aussi ça ça non non non et non mais il y
a différents types Decoup on peut
écouter comme tu as dit tout à l'heure
on peut écouter sans sans forcément
regarder alors qu'est-ce qu'on a dit
là c'est pas des devoirs c'est des des
exercices qui permettent de se de savoir
comment on fonctionne estce que je fais
face à mes problèmes est-ce que j'aime
le changement est-ce que j'aime les
nouveaux défis c'est toutes des
questions comme ça est-ce que je suis
logique par exemple tu vas répondre quoi
toi je te dirais j'essaie parce que
c'est compliqué de quand on a tellement
de choses bah normal j'ai tellement de
choses à faire que ça soit à l'intérieur
ou à l'extérieur là par exemple je ah
ouais il y a y a tellement tellement de
choses que franchement tu m'aurais connu
il y a 10 ans 15 ans arrière je t'aurais
dit oh il a ça ça ça à faire maintenant
il y a tellement de choses ouais mais je
vais pas te dire oui je sais je suis
logique j''y arrive non c'est pour ça
que'
exp justement je t'ai pas répondu
logique je t'ai dis c'est compliqué en
ce moment mais qu'est-ce que vous
appelez problème tu
vois l'incarcération ça casse ta tête et
avant tu tu retenais mieux tu
réfléchissais mieux ton vocabulaire
était 10 fois mieux pour moi tu
voisade ben oui mais pour retrouver tout
ça il faut mettre C il faut bouiner
beaucoup faut lire lire pour retrouver
le niveau le niveau de langage qu'on
avait vous lisez pas j'allais plus au
cinéma visiter des comment s'appelle des
musées comment des musées ouais des
musées mais là je suis dans tu avais une
vie de de ouais je je je me renseignis
sur beaucoup de choses c'est triste qui
quand même pourquoi c'est triste bah
parce que il devrait avoir envie de le
retrouver dans ce mais il a raison dans
ce qu'il dit il a raison moi je
comprends ce qu'il veut dire bon vas-y
je comprends pas tout mais vas-y moi je
comprends ce qu'il veut dire j'ai
compris c'est que ça l'a mis une cassure
exactement il y a un avant il y a un
après exactement alors là-dessus je suis
d'accord avec vous maintenant si vous
faites
le l'analyse de ce que vous avez fait
qui vous a conduit là mais vous
maintenant de ok je n'y retournerai pas
un are truc ça ah non c'est pas une
autre truc et c'est c'est un autre truc
ouais bah ouais ça relève d'un autre
truc c'est pas M c'est pas mélangeable
en gros moi je comprends ce que vous
dites ce que vous dites en gros ce qui
vous a amené là-bas et qui vous a fait
endurer ça et qui vous a causer cette c
parti de votre vie moi j'ai compris oui
je sais mais en gros vous voyez pas là
où lui la réinsertion en gros elle est
pas difficile elle est très très
difficile lui lui il constate maintenant
c'est sorti que le avant après c'est
plus dur que ce à quoi il s'attendait
des fois c'est même pas l'envie qui
manque he les difficultés auxquelles je
fais face elles sont plus puissante que
l'envie que j'ai moi qui m'anime tu veux
que je fasse quoi ça te paralyse bah
ouais ça te
paralyse
[Musique]
qu'on peut lui dire à cette à ce ce ou
cette juge c'est
que que toi tu es tu fais tout ce qu'il
faut pour pour aller bien et pour te
réinsérer euh mais ton frein là
aujourd'hui c'est ce
bracelet tu as vu le psychiatre tu
prends un traitement ou j'ai arrêé
vendredi
mais pasé voilà tu suis un traitement
enfin voilà
de un traitement
efficace qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
a d'autre là
il y a la
dictologue donc ça ça avec le psychiatre
dictologueors que je voudrais tu
recherches travail ou recherche tu peux
je me suis inscrit une formation
également je peux le mettre c'est tu en
as pas
parlé tu vois on a bien fait la
formation c'est quoi c'est une formation
pour la sonorisation expert mais
génial ça commence en
janvier ce qu'on va lui montrer c'est
que toi tu fais tout ce qu'il faut et
que tu as besoin qu'on te qu'on te
facilite la vie de pas avoir la charge
mentale du bracelet en plus et
contrainte inutile contrainte inu voilà
mais ça on peut le on peut les on peut
le le dire enfin c'est c'est une
contrainte inutile parce que tu es pas
du tout dans l'optique de parce que tu
es dans une optique positive de
réinsertion c'est une contrainte inutile
exactement on je vais le noter tu
vois bon allez à to
[Musique]
merci moi ça fait pas longtemps que je
suis dehors j'ai passé plus de temps à
prison que là ce que je vis à
l'extérieur maintenant donc c'est
compliqué tous les jours h il y a des
choses que j'arrive à gérer que je
trouve magnifique et il y a d'autres
choses que
voilà problématique et tout et peut-être
des fois je comprends pas ou des fois je
me perds et après voilà je perds pied je
me concentre plus et voilà Noël
j'entends bien des soucis personnels des
trucs et des machins ici la lucarne
comme je t'ai dis tu peux te t'appuyer
sur Lua pour les les résoudre un maximum
donc ça il faut détendre avec ça
ce que je je fais en ce que je pratique
là euh c'est de la sonorisation c'est ce
que je fais ici donc pourquoi je j'irais
pas plutôt vers euh la sono direct bah
ouais moi je pense et vu que toi déjà tu
as des connaissances dans le son
c'està-dire tu sais faire tourner un une
station audio numérique tu sais ce que
c'est à peu près de brancher un micro de
le faire fonctionner de ça tu as quand
même des des des tu as quand même des
bases tu vois faut pas te dire que tu
pars de zéro tu as des compétences il
faut juste que tu les organises en
fonction de ce qu'on demande déjà tu
vois sur un plateau de sonorisation on
va pas te demander ton certificat de
formation ça m'est jamais arrivé par
contre on va me regarder travailler si
je sais faire ce que j'ai à faire
brancher mes câbles faire mes retours
gérer ma console on s'en tape
complètement de savoir que j'ai fait une
école de son ou que tu vois donc en fait
il faut si un petit peu l'avantage des
métiers du spectacle vivant c'est qu'on
te juge sur pièce on te juge pas selon
tes ta batterie de diplôme et après faut
être disponible et surtout il faut être
fiable ça c'est tu dois être là tel jour
à telle heure faut que tu sois là
même si tu es au bord de mourir j'agère
tu vois ce que je veux
dire mais si tu réoles un précè qui n'a
pas de phase linéaire dans les têtes du
coup le préalignement dans le seble il
ve rien dire donc effectivement c'est ça
dont tu voulais parler mais ça ne se
passera que dans les têtes et dans
certaines voies des têtes tu fais
d'abord reverse polarity parce que tu as
ton 180 quasi partout tu reviens in
polarity tu es quasi une pH et après tu
mets un dél pur le sub oui je suis bien
en avance moi monsieur sub de 03 m
pourquoi c'est plus cool bah parce que
j'ai j'ai tenu compte des lois de la
physique si la célérité c'est la même
déplacement d'un frond la vitesse égale
si j'ai que 30 cm d'écart je vais pas
mettre un délai qui correspondra au fait
que mon sub il est 2 m 2 m en avant dans
la salle c'est pas vrai en fait
c'est complètement logique maintenant
que je l'ai redit ça va c'est plus clair
donc en fait bien considérer les
positionnements des sources et donc en
déduire les stratégies c'est
essentiel cherche pas le bypass
justement le bypass de quoi de mettre
notre rlage processeur à la place tu
vois du preset B ça toute façon on va
connecter on va connecter ma machine
dessus pour changer les cher ais du coup
John tu as une question dans user du
coup tu peuxom les qu canals de sortie
en fait c'est ça les qu canaux de sortie
c'est affecté X8 ou x12 ou alors en
custom tu pourrais faire canal 1 2 X8 et
Canal 3 4 x12 ok mais ça se fait via le
soft quit à perdre un peu de temps sur
les logiciels c'est pas mal d'écouter
aussi les choses parce que quelqu'un qui
aligne un système sans l'écouter aligner
un système c'est placer une sonde à un
endroit déterminé pour régler une
problématique si tu te goures sur le
placement de la sonde t alignement il
est valable que au point de la sonde
alors où est-ce qu'on mettrait ce micro
exactement là où on entend les deux
systèmes ouais elle était où la zone
d'ombre un petit peu bah au niveau là
justement du micro faut le reculer un
peu on on est en train de chercher
d'accord on n pas en train de construire
un truc de manière absolue c'est la
première fois qu'on construit un
gratciel je pense que les gars ils sont
gratté la tête avant de le faire mais
c'est pas c'est pas inatteignable
ok partez pas comme ça sortez des
carcans en fait ou des des habitudes
OK et ben bonjour donc moi je m'appelle
Caroline je suis dépendante et je suis
là aujourd'hui pour représenter
l'association narcotiqu
anonyme bonjour merci d'être là moi
c'est Stéphane je suis dépendant pareil
je suis membre de l'association
narcotique anonyme et on est là avec
Caroline pour vous présenter
l'association et vous partager nos
expériences
voilà content que vous soyez là ça me
touche en fait parce que j'ai je suis
passé 10 mois à la lucarne aussi voilà
nous ce qui nous ce qui nous uni à
narcotique anonyme ce qui nous ce qui
nous rapproche c'est l'état dans lequel
on est arrivé dans le désespoir total et
dans la souffrance dans laquelle on est
arrive dans ce programme moi je suis
arrivé je sortais du placard ça faisait
6 mois que j'étais sorti de la santé
j'ai mis à profit c'est 10 Mo
d'incarcération pour pour rien prendre
ça m'a voilà j'ai pas compris ce qui m'
arrivrivait parce que là bah forcément
mes émotions sont remontées j'ai repensé
à tout ce que j'avais fait tout le mal
que j'avais fait tous les morts que
j'avais laissé sur bord de la route que
j'avais pas pleuré parce que je
consommais à l'époque donc ça a été
super violent le soir j'ai pas honte de
le dire le soir j'étais en larme tous
les soirs dans ma cellule parce que
voilà c'était un constat sur le le chaos
que j'avais pu vivre et ce que je
m'étais fait vivre pendant toutes ces
années quoi je suis dépendant à tout je
suis dépendant au sexe je suis dépendant
à l'argent je suis dépendant à la cam je
suis dépendant au pouvoir au sucre à la
bouche ou la cigarette ça c'était c'est
plus ce problème là mais je suis
dépendant à tout je suis malade en fait
j'ai une maladie qui s'appelle la
dépendance moi si demain je vois une
moto dans une semaine j'ai une cagoule
et une arme dans la main parce que si je
me suis pas fait arrêter j'ai besoin de
monter d'aller plusv ça s'arrête pas en
fait voilà et et quand je consommais
c'était ça en fait comme le disait aussi
Caro moi je sais quelle heure il va être
quand je vais commencer à consommer je
sais pas quand ça va s'arrêter parce que
ça s'arrête jamais en fait ça s'arrête
quand je m'achève en fait voilà je me
finissais avec de l'alcool des cachets
pour pouvoir pour parce que euh tout
seul j'y arrivais pas et il fallait que
ça s'arrête j'ai 36 ans de consommation
active derrière moi tu vois donc euh
voilà c'est aujourd'hui je répare des
choses euh petit à petit voilà et ma vie
va beaucoup mieux moi j'ai amener de la
doc là euh je vais vous montrer ça alors
là vous avez là c'est une liste c'est
des ce qu'on appelle les listes de
réunion tu vois il y a toutes les
réunions sur Paris tuen veux non ça va
décon
he ah je travaille
V mais
là plus qu'à brancher le son aux
enceintes enfin la ou ouais la Conti quo
j' allumé le
truc c'est bon
l'audio il y a trois sont branché pour
l'instant tu te laisses traverser
[Musique]
ouais là je l'ai
pas
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu t'es trompé je
[Musique]
suisompé son
V
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fait un point sur
JB
pour recontextualiser JBI est en retard
à peu près de 2h30 tous les matins
depuis des mois
euh voir les posts de l'après-midi ça
c'est le plus fort hier on était plus
cool parce que c'était la grève bien
qu'il habite à un quart d'heure à pied
mais
bon et en fait il est parti la pose de
midi et après il est pas revenu
effectivement après manger avec Joris on
a fait le point des 3 mois de JBI et on
avait mis le cadre sur les retards en
disant ben en fait pour que tu te
protèges c'est pas nous qui faisons les
lois et qui faisons le droit du travail
mais quand tu es absent tes salariés il
faut soit que tu es un arrêt maladie et
tu te couvres soit euh effectivement tu
viens pas mais tu acceptes que tu
risques d'avoir des sanctions
disciplinaire derrière et cetera et
comme lui c'est très très récurrent ben
c'est problématique euh soit tu viens
mais tu un minimum dispo quoi et je
pense qu'il y a des vraies
problématiques derrière mais c'est je un
truc de maturité de comme on disait
beaucoup qu'il est pas disposé trop à
travailler quoi c'est ça donc la
sanction disciplinaire après la mise à P
c'est le licenciement licencier
quelqu'un c'est une
décision très
lourde et pour plein de raisons et du
coup j'ai jamais licencié personne
jusqu'à maintenant et donc j'ai voulu
que ce type de décision soit soumise
systématiquement au conseil
d'administration là pour le coup je suis
plutôt pour parce que il y a pas une
nonce de mouvement de sa part même un
mouvement à dire
quelque chose tu vois revendiquer
quelque chose genre j'y arrive pas vosir
il me
saoule non en fait il se passe rien on
peut acter clairement qu' travaille plus
chez nous en fait nous ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'il est plus au
travail on peut pas garder quelqu'un qui
n'est plus au travail pas passer notre
vie à écoper un bateau qui prend l'eau
en permanence tu vois ça c'est cl qu'
faut c'est une frontière qui est pas
toujours très très évidente à comprendre
que on est là pour comprendre leur
problématique a mais tout excus quoi
mais ça c'est une complexité du chantier
d'insertion je pense parce que dans
aucun travail sur la terre tu as une
journée de travail où tu es payé h oui
pour parler de tes problèmes et en fait
ça ça crée une confusion mais très
concrètement JBI il a saisi que la
prochaine étape c'est licenciement il
sait qu'après sa mise à pied il a plus
aucune chance j'aimerais bien le
recevoir bientôt mais la question c'est
quand est-ce qu'il va venir quoi
oui
est-ce que vous avez préparé déjà cet
après-midi vous savez de quelle
entreprise combien il y a de salariés
quel poste sur quel poste vous
postulezc bonjour monsieur assez-vous je
vous en prie alors vous venez candidater
donc sur le poste de technicien du son à
chez nous chez gthp oui plus ord
euh euh vous m'avez fait une lre de
motivation un CV d'accord je vois le
le le CV vous av vous dites avoir 20 ans
d'expérience dans dans la maîtrise le
matériel de diffusion l'installation de
de processus Sonor de captation de
montage son c'est bien ça
oui
euh dans quelle entreprise vous avez
travaillé auparavant pour pendant ces 20
ans plusieurs plusieurs entreprises euh
non en fait j'ai appris un autodidacte
en
fait j'ai le père d'un meilleur ami qui
effectuait des soirées privé
euh le weekend des mariages des
anniversaires vous êtes spécialisé sur
des progiciel des équipements en
particulier oui dites-moi quel quel
logiciel euh bah Pro Tools logique Cubas
enfin j'ai commencé sur Cubas sur Atari
d'accord euh après j'ai fait plein de
logiciels j'ai fait pr vous AZ un bon
niveau de maîtrise alors sur oui ça oui
franchement c'est maîtrisé même je
dirais un petit peu plus au-delà de ça
ok vous êtes disponible à partir de
quand
immédiatement donc je suis motivé je
suis disponible il y a aucun problème ok
euh et qu'est-ce que vous pourriez
amener à l'entreprise alors
euh
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous amener de
nouveau de neuf
de de rafraîchissant de de de
professionnels bah actuellement à la
lucarne d'Aran j'effectu des stages donc
je travaille énormément en équipe même à
la lucarne on travaille en équipe on a
aussi des sorties théâtrales avec un
résumé en équipe donc je suis souvent en
équipe j'essaie de de m'adapter et de
donner le meilleur de moi-même non parce
que vous allez travailler là sur les
hypotomes vous serez en petite équipe
donc parfois vous serez tout seul oui
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit oui euh en
autonomie aussi euh donc je voulais
savoir si vous êtes prêt à à être
autonome oui là dans dans la captation
et dans la je pense que je suis rapide
aussi équipement
ok on arrête là alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de cet exercice là m' piégé
direct pendant un moment j' t'is perdu
ah bon pour la Luc ouais pour la lucarne
voilà je sais pas s'il vont penser comme
moi mais ça on a fait plusieurs
associations qui qui sont pour la
réinsertion d'en parler c'est pas trop
bon est-ce que parce que c'est vrai que
la Lucar d'Ian si les gens vont se
renseigner ils pe ils savent que c'est
quelose se renseigne il a mon casier il
peut se dire aussi vas-y j'ai du cœur je
je pense que c'est à chacun de
développer son discours personnel parce
que c'est des questions personnelles
c'est vrai que à la fin il t'a demandé
tes qualités ce que tu as porté et
cetera tu as beaucoup parlé du travail
d'équipe ce qui est très bien après tu
as dit que tu étais capable de t'adapter
tout équip équipe mais tu as dit
beaucoup équipe et en fait c'est vrai
que ça par exemple quand on regarde une
offre d'emploi on peut regarder ok
qu'est-ce qui semble être les trucs les
plus importants un peu et souligner des
qualités qui sont vraies mais te dire
quelles sont les qualités les plus
pertinentes si on me le demande ton
argumentation il faut l'adapter à ce que
tu sais de l'entreprise tu vois c'est
que toi tu expliqué ce que tu avais fait
mais du coup il faut
pouvoir transférer si tu veux tes
connaissances dans un milieu particulier
à l'entreprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'été on a un festival qui s'appelle le
TAT festival et c'est notamment à ce
sujet
que on a imaginé ce temps de rencontre
puisque depuis l'an dernier on travaille
avec avec la lucarne
d'Ian
donc là on a quand même pas mal de
personnes de l'équipe qui sont présentes
et dou qui est notre régisseur général
voilà on propose des prestations où nos
techniciens sont mis à disposition pour
je ne sais pas vous avez un événement X
ou Y vous avez besoin qu'on fasse la
sonorisation la lumière on propose des
prestations de ce type là ok mais quand
ils viennent en renfort puisque l'idée
c'est de proposer des renforts en fait
c'est c'est quoi c'est c'est plutôt des
redises ou c'est des mecs qui sont déjà
jà capable de travailler sur une table
alors nous c'est pour ça que nous on
choisi par Chris il s'est géré une table
en trad il s'est géré les projecteurs
tradis après ils sont aussi là pour
entre
autres donner des coups de main dans une
équipe donc on va être très honnête ils
sont en formation donc voilà après il y
a pas que il y a pas que les compétences
non plus si on vous les propose c'est
qu'on estime qu'ils sont fiables aussi
parce que a une grosse prépa il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de manutes il y a tous
les extérieurs à faire il y a toutes les
salles à préparer il y a les loges et
ensuite s'intéresser à nos plans de Feu
à tous les projecteurs à trouver enfin
il y a toute la prépa quoi tu sais qu' a
pas que la prépa c'est vrai que c'est le
plus important mais aussi comme tu as
dit la manutention et j'ai passé les
cass et j'ai vu que tu avais une une
nelle une formidable
nasselle passé passé même tu peux me
ramener le plus gros camou j'arriveil
normal c'est cool pas maland il il sont
en lumièreon dansation quand ils sont en
lumière et on le fait passer le cass en
règle générale B voilà pas tu veux être
intermittent alors après ou pas ou tu
sais ce que tu ce qui tente euh pour
l'instant la lumière mais c'est vrai je
prendre sa place ok d'accord mais
attention
à bien raison place au
jeun place aux
jeunes c'est quoi comme lieu c'est la
Ressourcerie du spectacle ok trop cool
donc je
c'est ce Vitri donc c'est pas très loin
de chez moi ok ça supprime la contrainte
des transports déjà ça c'est incroyable
ouais c'est super ça fa du bien trop
bien et et du coup ils font de la la
récupération de matériel sonore de la
restauration de la mise en location voir
de la vente ah mais c'est parfait pour
toi je veux trop bien ce sera une de mes
dernières période de mise en situation
professionnelle si je peux en profiter
pour voir le maximum de de connaissance
et de compétences possible après tu
avais dans le mail un peu les détails de
ce que ça implique pour eux et tout ça
mais en soit c'est très c'est un peu
comme un spin c'est qu un stage gratuit
quoi ils ont pour eux c'est très çaz
avantageux ils ont aucune charge à part
le fait de t'encadrer quand même de pas
juste te faire travailler gratuitement
donc ce serait du 22 mai au 23 juin un
mois c'est parfait trop
chouette ça fait un an où est-ce que tu
en es
comment ça se passe j'ai beau j'ai beau
lire mémooriser enregistré c'est un
problème pour
moi j'essaie d'être
autonome mais même comme ça je je pense
que j' estce déj est-ce que tu te sens à
ta place est-ce que tu te sens bien à
l'endroit où tu es ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais bien sûr
ok bien sûr
je même des fois même quand je sais qu'
des choses que je peux pas faire tout
seul bah j'essaie de le faire tout seul
par mes propres moyens et voilà quoi
après au moment voulu quand tu poses des
questions par rapport au à la technique
et tout j'arrive à me débrouiller je
trouve que c'est
plutôt encourageant ce qui se passe enin
ton évolution là depuis le et surtout
les dernières semaines tu as chopé un
peu le rythme tu as chopé l'idée tu as
chopé pas mal de choses franchement tu
vois je trouve écoute tu donnes du tien
tu essayes de bien faire enfin c'est
quand même des choses qui sont
importantes pour moi l'évolution c'est
par exemple faire un plan de feu au
début je galéris mais je vois que je
vais de plus en plus vite et euh et
c'est là que je vois l'évolution ça veut
dire que tu avances c'est plus dans la
pratique c'est pour ça je t'ai dit en
pratiquant plus je pratique plus
j'évolue ça veut dire que tu avances
après tu as ton rythme d'avancecement on
est pas tous pareil dans ce rythme là ça
c'est pas tu vois je me dit bon j'ai pas
rresser alors moi je trouve de plus en
plus fiable et de plus en plus OK et ça
c'est vraiment vraiment trop cool euh
c'est pour ça qu'il y a pas de suspense
sur le fait que tu es renouvelé bien sûr
par
contre moi j'aimerais que le mardi ce
soit ta priorité absolu maintenant
d'être sur les offres d'emploi et même
il faut aussi j'allais venir arrêter de
croire que vous allez devenir régie
lumière en première expérience non mais
enfin tu vois quand tu es en
reconversion professionnelle c'est
normal de pas commencer au même niveau
que des mecs qui ont 30 ans d'expérience
dans le métier tu vois je pense que
c'est là où il y a la difficulté quoi
d'accord
ok
euh alors je vais avoir besoin de réglag
en pas trop fort au niveau au niveau de
des enceintes et pas trop fort au niveau
du micro mais il faut que je garde un un
équilibre un équilibre entre les deux
parce que je suis là en résidence cette
semaine j'ai pas besoin de que ce soit
trop fort
euh mais il faut que ce soit quand même
confortable est-ce que tu veux un petit
peu de Ré
enfin après on peut voir ça après mais
il y a de la réverbe sinon euh on va
tester euh je veux bien que tu me dises
ce que ça donne quand je parle estce que
je parle entre les morceaux he là si
ouais d'accord ok non parce que je parle
entre les morceaux et donc non
ok donc j'envoie j'envoie la musique
quoi
ouais est-ce que tu m'entends bien là et
et est-ce que il y a encore de r verb ou
pas non non ok
d'accord est-ce que tu as tu entend plus
quoi le son ou le ou
moi est-ce que c'est mieux comme ça pour
toi ok on va rester comme ça et moi ça
devrait aller 1 2 3 4
a ok ça devrait le faire ok c'est
[Musique]
bon
p
[Musique]